- Old videos?
- Let me see if I can remember
our old band login info.
[chuckling]
All right, here we go.
Look, look.
Look at how much
more interesting and
multi-faceted he used to be.
both: ♪ Handjobs ♪
♪ We love handjobs ♪
- ♪ Well the only job I ever
want to get is a handjob ♪
- ♪ You'll never see me doing
some stupid old man job ♪
♪ And if you do
please kick my ass ♪
- I would I could, buddy.
[sighs]
I guess those days are over.
- Is--is 38 million views a lot?
- Are you serious?
[stammering]
What is this?
Why is all this
written in gibberish?
- It appears to be Swedish,
Jeff.
Looks like you're a big hit
over there.
- Really?
- And look at this.
One of these guys is trying to
offer you a gig.
- Holy [bleep]!
- And look at this.
It says here you can get
stiffer, girthier erections
with this one weird trick.
- All right, well, we'll look
into this for one second,
and then we're gonna
call those Swedes.